G: It's happening.
G: Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now. Look who's here! It's Molly Burke.
G: She has transplanted to Los Angeles from the lovely Toronto, Canada, and I'm so happy that you're here. Literally we're in her -- M: this is the first time-
M: Time I am ever filming in this apartment, and you are here with me to do it.
G: Yay, we have a really fun challenge today. We are going to be decorating cakes: blind!
G: I mean you're gonna be doing that anyway. M: I decorate every cake blind and when I say I decorate every cake blind. I don't decorate cakes.
M: So it really- even though I'm blind and live every day without sight. It's still going to be a challenge for me
G: I have sight and this is going to be bad
I've actually done this one time before with my friend Mitchell, and it did not go very well
Mitchell: Okay, well my hand is in the  -- the stuff. G: Oh you're using your hands?
Mitchell: Are we not supposed to? G: You can, I didn't realize that would be an option I'm just trying to get the least amount.
Mitchell: How, how?
Mitchell: She's getting foundation on the -- she's got a lot of- her skin's bad. G: You only have to cover the top of the cake. We don't do the side.
Mitchell: Wait, what're mine?
G: Just the top. Mitchell: Oh, it's just the top. Then- where am I check me?
G: Mouth Mitchell: So I'm good?
G: Did I do a mouth? Can I move on to eyes? Mitchell: Is that enough? Mouth?
G: Hey, where's my other one!
G: Where's the eyes?
G: Where did the cake go?
G: Did I get eyes?
G: Did I get- am I done?
Mitchell: Am I done? G: Am I done yet?
Mitchell: What am I supposed to be feeling? G: Your cheeks and lips are the same colour!
Mitchell: Cheeks, cheeks.
G: Am I done? Am I done? Mitchell: NO, I'M DONE!
Mitchell: Come on!
Mitchell: Yeah, I was done at the same time.
M: I'm really interested to see what goes down here.
G: I got here and Molly and her mom had already made these funfetti cakes for us to decorate, so you guys have already
gone above and beyond. We have a bunch of different cake decorating apparatus.
M: So many options! G: And not only did they make cakes they made funfetti cakes.
M: Always the funfetti. I feel like the icing is honestly gonna be the most struggle. G:  And well we have knives. That's good
Okay, what have we decorated cake for each other? M: Aw...
G: Cause we're sweet. M: And then we eat them. G: Oh yeah, that's my favorite part of this game.
This is just all a big ruse to get the cake eating part of it. I say let's do like five minutes.
M: I think it's gonna take me five minutes
just to ice this. And I'm gonna put the blindfold on myself as well.
Just so that nobody can be like she's sighted. G: Right. M: She cheated. G: There's all these conspiracy theorists out there that really think Molly is sighted.
M: Which is hilarious. G: Go f*ck yourselves. M:  Thank you, Delta.
G: Oh, are these Delta-
M: My delta flight is providing us with blindfolds.
G: Oh my god, not advertised, not sponsored, but I mean reach out Delta. M: We're open to it. We're gonna have to open these.
M: Okay, and there is a napkin if you need it. I feel like hands are gonna be really involved with the icing. G: Hands are
a utensil, right? M: I hope you washed your hands, because I'm not eating that cake you haven't. G: Mom, are we set?
Molly's mom: Go!
M: Oh, I love with the spoon. G: Oh, and it's gonna devolve into hands immediately.
I'm sorry that I'm gonna destroy your kitchen. M: Okay, there's a nice like clean new carpet below me.
G: I feel like my cake is really becoming beautiful.
M: I'm glad you're confident in yours. G: Yeah...
M: I don't have much of it at this moment. G: If anything my hands have gone for a makeover.
M: I'm not bothering icing the edges. G: We haven't got time for that. M: We have so many options for decorations, which is great.
M: Oh, I had a plan for what I wanted the edges to look like and it's gone awry already.
G: I want to say I had a plan, but I didn't. M: My hands are so icing-y.
G: I think this is happening. I have some concepts in my mind, but I have a feeling it's not translating correctly.
Let's see where our other treats- Haha. M: Yeah gummy bears were an option. I'm not sure why
M: Breaking my brand-new bowl. G: Haha. M: You know I'm left-handed. Which is what you biggest issue here.
G: Like, I'm blind but my left handedness is stopping me.
G: Okay, I feel like my cake is coming to an end in terms of its decorating decoration. M: I'm almost done,
I'm just gonna attempt to write. G: Oh god bless. M: Which is going to be the real
downfall. G: I-
know that mine has not gone the way that I would have wanted it to, but art is not for interpretation.
It smells amazing in here by the way. M: It smells like a lot of funfetti.
M: I'm gonna say my fingers are sticky enough. G: Yeah. M: And I think that I'm done. G: Okay, I'm gonna say I'm done too. M: The reveal.
*suspense music*
G: Wow. Wow, yours is so pretty. M: It's supposed to say smile.
I don't know if it wrote anything.
G: Um, it definitely doesn't say anything. You can see the attempt to write smile. M: Okay.
G: But there is a dog hair in it. M: That really is the epitome of my life.
I have a guide dog his name is Gallop. He's like this big black dog. Everywhere I go
he stands on my left side guiding me, all the time
I just have hair all over me left side. G: You just gotta wear black pants all day. M: Not my aesthetic.
G: Not my aesthetic!
G: Well, speaking of Gallop, my cake is a tribute to Gallop.
It was supposed to be a dog shape on here, but it's kind of like a Warshak-
M: What did you make the dog shape out of? G: Every candy I could get my grubby hands on. I started to try and draw it with
some cake icing, but I felt like that wasn't going well.
So I tried to make a dog shape with all of the candy. It looks kind of like a butterfly.
M: Did you just kind of like throw them on and then try to mold it. G: Yeah... M: Is that the technique?
G: Yeah, it looks a little bit like a butterfly, a little bit like a crude penis.
Maybe a little bit like the letter I, kind of. It's not good. M: Well here
I have a smiley face, cause you make everybody smile and laugh. G: Aw god bless.
M: And then you have such a colorful personality, so we did the colors. G: Yeah,
you really nailed it. Yours looks like it's actually really well done.
M: And then it was supposed to say smile. That was gonna be like the finishing touch.
G: It's the thought that counts. Give us some comments down below
which cake did you love, which cake did you hate, you guys gonna tell us all those things anyway.
M: Would you- they're probably gonna be like I'm not gonna eat either of them because they're nasty. They had theit
hands all over them. G: Oh yeah, I'd
definitely pick out for like 10 minutes when I got here and then just put my hands in icing and put it on a
cake, so... This was really fun. I feel a domestic af,  like a domestic goddess.
M: I feel like a housewife. G: If you guys haven't already go check out Molly's channel. We're doing another thing
I'm terrible at. Identifying odors over on her channel, so go check that out, the link will be in description box below.
But go check out all of Molly's videos. She's super sweet, really funny and just an overall breath of fresh air. M: Oh...
Thank you. G: Thank you. Um. We'll see you guys next time.
I don't know. How do you barely have any icing on your hands? M: Um I used the napkin that we provided.
G: Oh, no. I'm just a trash monster. I went full out. M: I- I
utilized this to its fullest potential. G: Yeah, I'm like what's a napkin. What does that do? I don't know.